I'm Kevin Matthews the second author and
financial educator today I'll be
answering your questions from Twitter
this is money support
[Music]
at assarelis ask are we going into a
recession and what does recession mean
again that's a great question a
recession by definition is two
consecutive quarters of negative GDP
that is gross domestic product is
essentially the amount of stuff we
produce as a country q1 of 2022 was
negative and then Q2 of 2022 was also
negative so technically yes we are in a
recession one thing that's stopping us
from officially calling this a recession
is the National Bureau of economic
research they take in a number of
factors including GDP unemployment
consumer spending and other factors and
so far they have not yet declared the
official recession at I'm adult-ish
asked seriously who is trusting me with
a credit card and how on Earth is my
credit score calculated I don't know
who's trusting you with a credit card
however I can tell you how your credit
score is calculated so there are five
main factors 35 percent of it is based
on your payment history are you paying
that credit card on time thirty percent
of it is going to be your credit
utilization this is the amount of the
credit limit that you are using
generally you want to stay below 20 to
30 percent 15 is credit length how long
have you held this particular credit
line or credit card open this is why if
you have had a credit card for several
years and you close one that's going to
bring down the average credit link 10 is
new credit so this is when you apply for
a new credit card you want to be very
careful your score does tend to dip
during those times and then the last one
is credit mix this is the mix between
credit cards mortgages student loans and
other things they want to make sure that
you can pay different types of debt and
you have a diversified credit portfolio
at financially underscore bot ass how
soon do I need to start saving for
retirement yesterday you want to make
sure that you are taking advantage of
time because time is your biggest assets
the longer you invest the more you're
going to have compounding interest
compounding interest is when your money
makes money so for example let's say I
make 100 and I receive 10 interest on
that I have made ten dollars the next
time that I take that money and invest
it and get 10 again that ten dollars
also makes ten percent so the money
makes more money so one of the pushbacks
I get when people ask this is well yeah
you gotta wait 20 years or 30 years for
that to pay off it does however the time
is going to pass anyway I'd rather start
now and 10 years from now you're gonna
wish you started 10 years ago at Stan
said airport how do you become a
millionaire so becoming a millionaire is
essentially having at least one million
dollars in net worth there are 7.5
million Americans who have reached
millionaire status that's about two and
a half percent of the entire U.S
population now how you do this there are
multiple ways business ownership ship
the stock market and real estate are the
most common ways to become a millionaire
the other thing is be patient wealth is
going to depend on time and the more
time you take the easier it's going to
be and the more you can take advantage
of compounding interest Robert Wright
asks is our tax system rigged for the
rich 18 billionaires exploited tax
loopholes to get Federal stimulus checks
at the height of the pandemic what do
you think the answer is yes there are
plenty of tax breaks that
disproportionately impact and help those
who are wealthier one of the most famous
examples is the fact that you can write
off a portion of your mortgage interest
well guess what ninety percent of
millionaires do own a home those who do
not have the money to buy homes do not
get this particular Advantage another
one that tends to get a lot of news
coverage is the capital gains tax rate
so if I make money from buying and
selling stocks the highest tax bracket
that I would pay is 20 however if I took
that same income and worked a regular
nine to five job the highest income rate
there is 37 if you are a
multi-millionaire or a billionaire in
many cases a lot of your wealth is
usually tied up into a stock if you were
to sell that stock that means that you
would pay taxes on it however what some
people do is loan themselves the money
based on the value of that stock because
when you are receiving a loan you're not
paying any taxes on it because it
doesn't count as income that's another
way that very wealthy people tend to
manipulate the tax code and kind of get
around things so they can lower their
tax burden at Warren Myers asked why do
so many people go to college when they
return on investment is so poor says who
when you look at the median return on
investment for a lifetime for those who
went to college the median return is 287
percent however it is negative 41 in the
first 10 years so over time most college
degrees do pay off we talk about return
on investment especially for a college
degree this is a relationship between
how much you make from having that
degree and how much you paid either
lower the cost by going to an in-state
State School sometimes it's going to the
Community College and you're lowering
the cost for that degree or you can make
significantly more money for paying the
exact same cost this is why you see some
engineering Majors those who went to
school for engineering they have a
higher return investment because their
degree pays more however across the
board I think we can all agree that
college is also too expensive and should
be made more affordable across the board
at alawatsunu underscore Esq asks can
someone explain what a treasury bond is
to me like I am a five-year-old so I
have a four-year-old at home so I'm
gonna do my best dad impression on how I
can explain a treasury bond uh to a
five-year-old a choice rebond is a loan
that you make to the US government and
the US government is going to promise to
pay you back on a certain date we call
this the maturity date and also during
this time they're going to guarantee you
interest on that principle on the amount
that you loan now treasury bonds are
considered to be among the safest
investments in the world because as long
as the US government is collecting taxes
you are going to get some portion of
your investment back when we're talking
about treasury bonds your returns are
typically pretty low right now for a
10-year treasury bond you're looking at
close to three percent so you could
invest 100 and just get back three
that's not necessarily motivating
because inflation is above eight percent
so for most investors especially those
on the younger end usually want to take
on more risk maybe that's a stock maybe
that's an index fund to gain higher
returns and are more likely to build
wealth because the treasury bond isn't
necessarily the best way to grow your
money but it is one of the best ways to
protect your money at Max sebasti asks
how much debt is too much debt that is a
great question and there is a metric for
this this is called the debt to income
ratio once you hit 43 that is a red flag
if you are bringing in ten thousand
dollars per month and forty five hundred
dollars of that is going to debt
payments then that is far too much
because that is going to leave you at 45
on your debt to income ratio when you do
that and you are applying for a loan
then they're going to look at this debt
to income ratio because they want to
make sure they're going to get their
money back for their loan so they do pay
a lot of attention to that debt to
income ratio you hit above 43 that's
going to raise a red flag honestly when
you look at 36 percent they're also
going to raise an eyebrow at that as
well at keep more money ask what does a
realistic budget look like for me a
realistic budget is 50 30 20s call the
50 30 20 rule because you want to have
50 of your income for your expenses you
want to have 30 for fun money you can
enjoy and then 20 for savings and
investing regardless if it's 30 or lower
you should have room in your budget to
enjoy that's going to help you to stick
to your budget when you max out
everything and everything is going to
savings and everything is going to build
and you don't have time to enjoy or you
don't have money to enjoy the things
that you want you're not going to stick
to that budget that can lead you into
debt and put you in a situation that is
not conducive to your Financial Health
at covered in words ask what investment
benchmarks do you use what is your
investment philosophy so I love this
question when we talk about benchmarks
it is basically how am I measuring My
Success am I investing well or am I
behind the curve in most cases I use the
S P 500 the largest 500 companies this
is a very standard Benchmark I would say
this is like the the basics that you
should use as your investment Benchmark
what is my investment philosophy
personally I'm a Buy and Hold investor I
primarily hold index funds and what we
call Blue Chip stocks stock stocks we
all know and have heard of before and
when you are a Buy and Hold investor
again you're buying you're holding it's
boring but it is quite effective at Tava
2 as asked where do you start with
buying slash trading stocks what do you
buy what to sell and how do you know WTF
you are doing that is a great question
the first thing is you have to define a
goal when you are looking to buy socks
or if you're looking to trade the reason
why I say that is because your goals are
going to determine what account type you
use is going to determine what stock you
buy and then when you sell so for
example if I'm looking to make ten
dollars that's going to tell me when to
get out of a stock if I'm looking to
build wealth over time that's going to
tell me to buy something that's more
stable and something that may hold for
quite a while now the second half of the
question is how do I know what I'm doing
what I tend to do is browse the company
website we all know how much X company
is making per year we can all see who
the CEO is and whether or not their
products are working or not and you can
use that to start to understand whether
or not that makes sense for you to own
at nft ignition as if you can't buy the
dip just survive it what does that mean
basically don't sell if you are down
let's break this down so the first thing
is buying the dip this is a time that
started off in the stock market and it
essentially means that if you believe
that a stock is going up and it comes
down temporarily in price that is a dip
because you believe it is going to
continue to rise not every dip is a
discount and not every dip is worth
buying a stock is different than a
cryptocurrency all of them dip but not
all of them have the same track record
for recovery for example the stock
market as a whole since 2000 has been
negative only five times from 2000 to
2021. buying the dip for the stock
market definitely makes sense is that
the same thing for crypto is it the same
thing for nfts that question is still up
in the air now another question is what
if that dip keeps dipping what if it is
not a dip but a cliff and just falls off
you have to understand what you are
investing in understand the risk and set
limits for yourself so in some points
you have what is called a stop loss
where you can say look if this asset
Falls to a certain price I'm going to
get out of it I'm going to take my lumps
and go take my ball and play somewhere
else at dancing underscore cookie ask
Dollar Tree is now 1.25 what's next for
inflation Arizona Iced Tea so first off
Arizona Iced Tea is far too expensive it
used to be 99 Cents food prices are much
higher than what they were last year or
even two or three years ago but if you
look back at some of the old magazines
and things of that nature you could have
got a Coke for five cents you could have
got a burger for 10 cents now these
things are costing 5 10 15 for both
inflation slowly over time does increase
prices for us all the problem however is
when it happens in what feels like
overnight from 2021 to 2022 for example
we just got an inflation report that
said food prices are up 10 from what
they were last year inflation is what
happens when we have too much money
chasing too few goods now the solution
to this is to either increase Supply or
reduce demand the way we reduce demand
is by increasing interest rates and
that's what you are seeing from the
Federal Reserve right now at genexical
ask can someone tell me how and where I
should be investing my money this is
probably the most common question I get
all the time for most of us you want to
have what we call a long-term
Diversified portfolio for most people
this comprises of just stocks and bonds
you have others that include real estate
and even business ownership so when I'm
looking to move forward to be more
aggressive I'm going to have more stocks
and then when I'm looking to slow down
and survive bumps that I want to have
bonds the older you get the more this
mix is going to change is a term called
asset allocation the closer you are to
retirement the more bonds you'll have
the younger you are typically the more
you want to have in stocks at gives zero
FX so is it too late to get in on this
crypto thing laughing emoji depends on
what you are looking for so crypto is
known to be very volatile there are
violent jumps both up and down in the
crypto space something like Bitcoin if
you go back even over the last five to
eight years there are times where that
asset is down 90 there are other years
worth up 400 if you are someone looking
to get rich tomorrow you might have
missed that boat if you're looking to
invest in crypto long term there is a
case to be made where it does make sense
however the general recommendation here
is to have five percent or less of your
overall portfolio invested in crypto if
you want to be more aggressive you are
more than welcome to but remember these
assets are risky many of them are
unproven and they are very again
volatile for your portfolio at index and
ETFs ask what is the main advantage of
index funds and ETFs over mutual funds
you can have an index ETF that tracks
the S P 500 and you can also have an
indexed mutual fund that tracks again
the S P 500 the 500 largest companies in
the US they do the same things but the
mechanics behind them are a little bit
different ETFs usually when it comes to
fees are significantly less expensive
and there are no minimums in most cases
an index ETF is going to allow me to do
that at almost any dollar amount
compared to an indexed mutual fund which
may have a two thousand dollar minimum
or one thousand dollar minimum so when
you are comparing an ETF to mutual fund
an index ETF to an index mutual fund it
comes down to fees and minimums and
those are the biggest advantages for
atfs over mutual funds so those are all
the questions that we have today thank
you for spending your time with me and
thanks for watching money support